well you can't realistically ban
encryption because it's the duct
tape that holds online systems together
um
it's how you protect your communications
from your browser on your laptop or on
your mobile phone to your bank or to a
shop where you're shopping
it's not just that if you use a
pre-payment electricity meter for
example and you put in a 20-digit magic
number when you've gone about 20 quids
worth of more
juice then that's cryptography that is
enabling you to take that transaction
from the shop where you spent the money
to the meter where you're going to burn
the electricity
it's used in hundreds and hundreds of
different ways to just hold the whole
things together
encryption we've got politicians at the
moment saying we need to get rid of it
or
be able to be read by our security
services or whatever
what's the reality of of how that could
work or what would happen
the reality is that a little bit over 20
years ago there was another attempt to
ban cryptography
because just after bill clinton got
elected president of the usa
the nsa went in to see him and they made
the sales pitch that he should bring in
key
escrow the duty on everybody who uses
cryptography to give a copy of the
cryptographic key to the nsa and they
tried to introduce something called the
clipper chip
which had a government backdoor key
baked into it but a friend of mine matt
blais brought the clipper chip which
caused great embarrassment and
humiliation to the nsa
so they come back with other proposals
one they had in britain
was that we should have to use trusted
third parties and that if you're going
to use cryptography
you would have to have the key certified
by someone like
you know verisign or barclays bank or
bt who would keep a spare copy for the
cops in case it was needed to decret
your stuff
and we had all sorts of fights about
this for example
just after tony blair got elected he
went back on a pre-election promise
he promised that he wouldn't ban
cryptography and then al gore went and
talked to him and he changed his mind
and so what we did in a hurry was to
print the
thousand or so most important
cryptographic keys
on the internet into a book and i've got
a copy here
and this is the global internet trust
register so we went to see chris smith
who was the cultural secretary and we
said chris
your government's about to ban books
it's about to ban my book here
and we showed him all the cryptographic
key material in it we said you're the
minister for books
what are you going to do about this that
at least got it onto the agenda of the
cabinet meeting and it didn't just go
through on the nod
and there was a huge big row in
kerfuffle and it eventually got handed
off by dti who had been pushing it to
the home office that were prepared to
push it a bit more brutally
and it ended up becoming the regulation
of investigatory powers
to act 2000 and in the end all the act
requires in respect of cryptography is
that if the police want to decrypt
something
and they believe that you've got the key
for it then a chief constable can sign
an order
for you to do that decryption and
this was where we thought we had um
you know got an agreement on how
cryptography and policemen could live
happily together
now all of a sudden uh the cops are back
and they're asking for more
so to just remind me again so that was
20 years ago that was that's right
how do they go 20 years and think okay
right hang on we'll have another crack
at this i wonder
i think what's happening in the usa is
that fbi
director james comey wants to scare
apple and facebook
to not use cryptography as pervasively
and as competently as they do
in products like what's happened
facetime
here in britain i think that david
cameron's just jumping on the bandwagon
and he's adopting this in order to look
tough and strut and appear to be tough
on terror
and tough on the causes of terror but in
reality
a law like this isn't going to happen
because it would have to happen in
america for its of any effect
and congress in america can't make laws
at the moment
so it's basically bluff and bluster and
posturing between
american tech titans on the one hand and
american intelligence agencies on the
other
all of them seem to be forgetting that
even the most mundane of transactions
relies on this
encryption so it's not just a matter of
transactions relying on encryption in
many cases
the tech mergers have brought in
encryption in order to avoid
the problems that are being caused by
law enforcement itself
now if you're a google one of the big
problems you face
is that a family court in india
may serve you an order telling you to
hand over the gmail of somebody in
canada who's never been to india
and putting on a lifetime secrecy order
now
how can you simultaneously give
believable assurances of privacy to your
users in canada
and also employ engineers in india well
what the big firms do at the moment is
they just insist that their lawyers in
california are involved in approving
every single decision
to hand over stuff to law enforcement
agencies
and the police really don't like that
the police in britain for example really
don't like the fact that they've got to
phone up facebook's call center
of their abuse team in ireland and say
please in order to get access to stuff
they would rather be able to serve
warrants and tell people to shut up and
just hand it over
but that's not going to happen in a
globalized world
you can't have a world where 200 odd
countries police forces can all have
surreptitious access
access to your staff without you ever
hearing about it
so if you're a tech major how do you
deal with this well quite simply you
encrypt the traffic end to end
and that means that if mi5 comes up with
a warrant of the russian secret police
or the chinese people security police or
whatever
and they say hand over ross anderson
stuff then facebook or apple or google
can just shrug
say search us we don't have it that's
the ciphertext it's only the endpoints
of the key
this episode of computerval was brought
to you by squarespace
you can start building your website
today at squarespace.com
if you enter the offer code computer
file you'll get 10
off their plans start at 8 a month and
if you sign up for a year you'll get a
free domain
so start your free trial today at
squarespace.com
you don't even need to put in your
credit card details and if you're a real
computer file you might want to check
out the developers platform
developers.squarespace.com just remember
that code
computer file for 10 off
if you want to send me a message i don't
have to share anything with you
you just know my public key encrypt
something with my public key
send it to me you know i can decrypt it